DESPITE WHEN ASKED ABOUT IT WERE
COGNIZANT ABOUT PROCESS.
>> BEYOND THE POLITICS, DOES
THIS FIX A BROKEN SYSTEM?
>> THIS DOES VERY LITTLE TO
ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING PROBLEM,
WHICH IS THE COST OF COLLEGE.
IT PAYS OFF FOR MOST PEOPLE, I
SHOULD BE CLEAR.
IT'S AN INVESTMENT THAT PAYS OFF
FOR MOST PEOPLE, NOT EVERYONE.
THERE'S A LOT OF FLY BY NIGHT
OPERATIONS THAT PRODUCE DEGREES,
BUT ARE WORTHLESS, A LOT OF
STUDENTS NEVER GRADUATE, THEY
TAKE ON THE DEBT, AND NEVER GET
THE BENEFIT OF THE DEGREE.
THIS DOESN'T SOLVE ANY OF THAT.
SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT WERE
ANNOUNCED WILL EFFECTIVELY MAKE
COLLEGE CHEAPER FOR PEOPLE IN
THE SENSE THAT THE CHANGES TO
THE INCOME DRIVEN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS WILL CAP THE PAYMENTS
THAT PEOPLE MAKE BY MONTH,
ESSENTIALLY, AND THEN HAVE THEIR
BALANCE FORGIVEN MUCH SOONER
THAN THE CASE UNDER CURRENT LAW.
MAYBE COLLEGES RAISE TUITION
BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN BORROW MORE
BECAUSE MORE WILL BE FORGIVEN.
>> THE CRITICS POINT FIRST TO
THE COST OF THE PROGRAM.
WHAT'S THE IMPACT MORE BROADLY
ON THE ECONOMY?
>> I THINK THERE ARE A FEW WAYS
YOU CAN THINK ABOUT THIS.
IT'S THE ACTUAL IMPACT OF THE
DEBT WHICH DOESN'T GO AWAY.
IT JUST SORT OF SHIFTS HANDS
FROM THE BORROWER TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND THE IMPACT ON CONSUMER
SPENDING AND OF COURSE
INFLATION, WITH INFLATION AT
8.5%.
SO THE ARGUMENT IS THAT IN
PAUSING THE REPAYMENT, WHICH
SOME ECONOMISTS, CERTAINLY LARRY
SUMMERS AND OTHERS HAVE SAID IN
PAUSING THAT REPAYMENT YOU HAVE
ALLOWED PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO
SPEND AS THEY HAVE BEEN.
FOR EXAMPLE, LET'S SAY THE
AVERAGE STUDENT LOAN PAYMENT IS
$300 PER MONTH, AND IT IS BEFORE
THE MORATORIUM.
IF THOSE WERE TO START NEXT
MONTH, SUDDENLY YOU HAVE $300
LESS TO SPEND IN THE ECONOMY,
AND THAT WOULD BE
DISINFLATIONARY.
OTHERS, HOWEVER, SAY THESE
PAYMENTS, THEY HAVEN'T HAD TO
PAY IN TWO YEARS, SO HOUSEHOLD
BUDGETS ARE WHAT THEY ARE, AND
SO THERE IS A LOT OF FIERCE
DEBATE.
JASON BERMAN TWEETING THIS IS
RECKLESS.
THERE'S DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER
THIS ADDS TO THE INFLATIONARY
FIRE.
THAT SAID, IT CERTAINLY PROVIDES
RELIEF FOR SOME WHO NEED IT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID 43 MILLION
PEOPLE WILL QUALIFY FOR SOME
RELIEF.
20 MILLION WILL HAVE ALMOST ALL
OF THEIR DEBT FORG